today we are competing to see who can
make the best ramen rumble lasagna
this is a tick tock trend you might have
seen it it looks pretty simple it's only
cheese pasta sauce and ramen noodles how
can you mess that up i won't be cocky
i'm going to be humble throughout this
whole process let me wash my hands
hold on sorry
oh my god how do you open it
it's so stuck together
how do i open this
oh
i'm nervous i'm messing this up already
we got our tomato sauce let's pour this
half cup on half a cup feels like a lot
oh
i'm doing it oh she thick
easy oh my god this is sloppy don't come
for me great mozzarella cheese on top
we're gonna need scissors i'm all over
the place here we go so we've already
come to our first potential roadblock i
don't have mozzarella cheese the only
cheeses that i have are cheddar and
monterey jack boom we got a cheese are
you kidding me talk about cinematic
experience look at that
look
it's not too bad i mean you can't go
wrong with too much cheese right
bam
well now we're gonna do a little cheddar
mix it up a little bit
[Music]
this is so hard if this is edible at the
end of this that's a win for me okay i
know i'm like going off book right now
but like what if we throw a little chili
oh that looks good another layer of
instant ramen
okay literally perfection i'm making a
mess followed by more tomato sauce and
more mozzarella cheese okay literally
chef
this isn't working
look at that
look at that let's do a little of this
cheese guys this is gonna be so gross my
arms are burning
there we go
beautiful i could eat this right now i
won't but i could it appears as though
we will be baking for about 45 minutes
on 350 degrees that oven is preheating
which is why i look like i'm sweating
like a hog right now
[Music]
here
is the final product
boom so i cooked it like seven minutes
too long does it show absolutely yes are
you kidding me did i really just make
this i don't think my odds are looking
too hot we're going to give it a try
[Music]
oh it's good
[Music]
it's just weird
not bad honestly kind of delicious okay
i'm changing my mind it's delish
oh my gosh look at that steam that looks
so good i do think the addition of the
chili powder was smart
that
the woman is going for seconds i won
game over
boom no points for me
but i'm gonna eat it all anyway okay bye
that is pretty darn good
you